a new protest staged by supporters of
shayat leader muqtada
this time in front of the supreme
judiciary council inside baghdad green
zone
they want the head of the supreme
judiciary council to resign and the
judiciary system to be reformed
we have been instructed by our leader to
protest here against the corrupt
judiciary system which is manipulated by
iran for years it has been collaborating
in impunity committed against the iraqi
people
we will be protesting until the
parliament is dissolved and inequitable
laws and constitutional articles are
amended
supporters of the shayat leader emerged
as the biggest party in parliament
following elections in october but they
were unable to form a government and
resign their seats two months ago
sadr's supporters have camped outside
the parliament for nearly a month
calling for it to be dissolved and early
elections held
but that's provoked the rivals raising
concerns of conflict
a counter protest is being held outside
the fences of the green zone
by supporters of the iranian-backed
parliamentary bloc known as the
coordination framework alliance or cfa
the latest escalation seems to be a
backlash against southern's movement
the supreme judiciary council has opened
an investigation into threats against
its staff by his supporters
and issued an arrest warrant against
approved other prominent politicians
the cfa has suspended all dialogues
other supporters until they end what
they call the occupation of the state
institutions
now the coordination framework has more
allies and more points for negotiation
they can embolden it to move on with
forming a government without members of
sardis party being part of it
earlier this month
southern rejected a national dialogue
initiative offered by caretaker prime
minister mustafa al-qademi
the supreme court has been handling
constitutional disputes between rival
parliamentary blocs
but southern side blames it for
derailing the formation of government
now with the country's judiciary system
at the heart of this conflict
many are questioning the integrity of
the iraq's political system